[Music]
xbox1 earnest christmas has come early
this year or Easter or your birthdays I
don't know Microsoft has announced a new
Xbox one update is coming and this is a
bad intro this bring update will bring
support for 1440p resolution for games
and media as you may already know this
res sits between 1080p and 4k and has
1.5 million more pixels than 1080p of
course you will need a supported TV to
reap the benefits the update also brings
new audio options so if you like to
listen to music while you play certain
games like I do you can now balance game
audio against background music apps the
Xbox one also now supports spatial audio
for system sounds and from now on audio
cues will match the action you see on
screen to your surround system should
you have one of those on top of all
those goodies mixer that Microsoft
streaming service you're totally using
is getting some new features you can now
virtually share your Xbox one controller
with the viewer who is watching on
Mexico so they can take control by way
of an on-screen gamepad or by plugging
in a controller to their PC so Xbox one
club admins you can now filter by
reputation gamer score and
recommendations from other Club members
so if you only want the best of the best
for your pub G group you could filter by
players with over 200 hours logged for
example or end up with someone who just
leaves it on the idle screen a lot
Microsoft is also now allowing you to
disable comments on content shown in
clubs and game hubs and community tabs
and they've introduced open tournaments
so you no longer need to be in a club to
start or join a tournament the new
spring Xbox one update is available now
to play as in the Xbox Insider alpha
ring it'll roll out to other testers
after that while a public release will
follow down the line for more updates on
this one stay tuned to games but
[Music]